sometimes a scientific study reveals
things that were never expected to be
part of the discovery while conducting
forensic Studies on human decomposition
scientists in Canada found deep-sea
dwelling animals taking a chance and
going after a pig carcass where oxygen
is at extremely low levels pigs are used
in decomposition studies because they
are anatomically similar to humans the
4th Pig deployment in the study was the
most dramatic recorded in the Strait of
Georgia British Columbia
several sixgill sharks annihilated the
carcass eliminating it within a day at
more than 900 feet below sea level it's
at depths like this that oxygen drops to
very low levels leading to the term dead
zones in recent years dead zones are
occurring more frequently in many areas
of the ocean the lead researcher Verena
Tunnicliffe of the University of
Victoria said the scientists were very
surprised to see how far animals push
their limits to go after an enticing
meal in this video recorded in British
Columbia's Saanich Inlet the first
animal on the scene was a squat lobster
over several days scientists observed
more squat lobsters coming for a meal as
well as crabs and shrimp this pig
carcass was devoured by the 23rd day
according to dr. Tunnicliffe the pigs
used at MIT study coordinated with
Canada's Venus Project were originally
raised for market they were euthanized
humanely under strict government
regulations the findings were presented
at a meeting of the American Geophysical
Union in Portland Oregon this week the
scavenger animals usually hang out at
shallower depths where oxygen levels are
higher but the pig carcasses attracted a
daring crowd
if the crabs squat lobsters and other
animals stay too long in oxygen-depleted
waters they will suffocate one pig in
the experiments at untouched for nearly
two months apparently because the oxygen
level is too low to support the hungry
scavengers the findings will help
scientists in their study of other
locations such as the Mississippi Delta
where fertilizer from upstream
agricultural runoff lowers oxygen levels
the so called dead zones also diminish
the success of fishermen's attempts at
catching shrimp crab and other
commercial species
[Music]